[Musique]
la permaculture
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est je
vais vous dire ce que c'est la
permaculture
ce sont tout simplement des
installations humaines où la nature a
été reproduite au fait c'est juste une
copie de la nature il y a plusieurs
définitions de la permaculture
il y en a une particulièrement que
j'aime c'est celle qui définit la
permaculture comme un système où on
travaille avec la nature vous savez
qu'on travaille avec la nature cette
nature devient tellement généreuse on se
retrouve dans un environnement très
agréable avec des aliments sains et
abondon et en plus la terre au lieu de
s'appauvrir devient beaucoup plus
fertiles et plus vivante
ce qui m'a séduit dans la permaculture
au fait c'est son système
c'est un système vraiment fabuleux qui
transforme les déchets en ressources lé
problème en solution
on va prendre une cour où il y a
beaucoup de végétation
il y a beaucoup d'arbres des plantes des
fleurs qu'il faut tailler on va le
tailler et on se retrouve avec une
montagne de déchets verts qu'est ce
qu'on fait d'habitude avec ce tas de
déchets verts
je vais vous dire ce qu'on fait
d'habitude en prend ce tas de déchets
verts on le met sur le bord de la route
pour que la commune le voiture de là le
camion de la commune viennent le
ramasser ou alors on va le mettre dans
un coin de la cour pour le brûler plus
tard par contre si on utilise ce tas de
déchets verts pour le transformer en
broyat on peut utiliser ce broyat pour
alimenter son sol pour nourrir sans
sommes là à ce moment là les déchets se
sont transformés en ressources et le
problème est devenu la solution
il y a
longtemps j'ai lu dans la bible dans le
livre de job
un passage qui dit parle à la terre
elle renseigne là à ce moment là je ne
comprenais pas grand chose j'ai trouvé
le passage très poétique mais ça s'est
arrêté là
mais maintenant j'ai compris j'ai
compris ce que ça veut dire par là la
terre et elle enseignera à force de
côtoyer la nature et d'être entourée
d'une diversité végétale
à force de travailler dans la terre et
de prendre le temps d'observer chaque
petit insecte qui ont chacun un travail
particulier à faire à force de voir ces
oiseaux qui picorent les flics j'ai
commencé à réaliser qu'il y avait les
motos de nous un monde un monde de se
créer un mode de connaissance qu'on n'a
pas encore découvert et qui attend
de se révéler il y a tellement de choses
à vendre dans la nature que ça nous
prendrait toute une vie pour tout savoir
et encore je me rappelle d'une visite
que j'ai fait dans mon jardin
j'aime beaucoup me promener dans mon
jardin est aussi pouvoir
si tout se passe bien et bien sûr tout
ne se passe pas toujours bien dans un
jardin c'est comme dans la vie dans le
jardin séparé soit parce que les poulets
ont fait des dégâts dans une parcelle de
culture ou alors les petits oiseaux en
picorer tous les fruits mûrs ou alors
les limaces en manger les haricots la
salade
ce sont des choses qui arrivent et donc
pendant la visite
et ce jour là j'ai eu eu quelque chose
j'ai vraiment l'impression que je ne
pouvais plus me permettre d'avoir des
pensées négatives parce que je sentais
que mes plantes captent et mes émotions
et vous voyez ce qui se passait dans mes
pensées
j'ai vraiment eu une sensation très
étrange
je me suis dit d'habitude ce sont les
plantes qui ont de l'impact surnom est
là à ce moment là j'ai l'impression
j'avais de l'impact sur les plantes
comme si j'avais un certain pouvoir
serait
vous savez après ce jour là j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi je me suis dit si la
permaculture est un concept positif qui
transforme le problème en solution ce
n'est pas du tout normal de ma part
d'avoir des pensées qui ne vont pas dans
le sens de la solution et après
réflexion j'ai décidé d'avoir des
pensées positives parce que vous savez
la nature nous regarde la nature nous
observe
non seulement nous observe et à s'attend
à ce que nous comportions et que nous
pensions positivement c'est quoi
travailler avec la nature pour moi ce
n'est pas simplement se limiter à
respecter les normes naturel des choses
c'est aussi penser positivement
c'est très bien de de jeter les déchets
de cuisine dans un composteur pour faire
du compost c'est très bien tout le monde
devrait le faire
c'est très bien aussi de broyer ses
déchets verts pour alimenter son sol et
ça aussi tout le monde devrait le faire
et c'est tellement important de re veut
redonner à la nature ce qu'on appuie de
la nature est ce que j'ai réalisé aussi
c'est que les arbres les plantes les
berges de terre les uns c'est que les
animaux les cailloux sont comme des
partenaires
ils ont un rôle fondamental à jouer à
jouer en notre faveur
c'est quoi encore travailler avec la
nature j'ajouterai c'est aussi être
sensible à ce comportement et lui venir
en aide
je vais prendre le cas de mon pied de
tomate
j'avais planté deux beaux pieds de
tomates dans mon potager trou de serrure
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est un
potager tout seul je vais vous dire ce
que c'est c'est un potager carré ou
circulaires avec 1 to au milieu et un
petit passage pour aller à ce trou ça
ressemble vraiment un truc sérieux et
c'est très bon pour les petits terrains
et dans ce trou se troue sert à ajouter
tous les déchets de cuisine bien sûr
sans les protéines animales
j'avais donc planté deux pieds de
tomates dans ce potager trou de serrure
avec d'autres légumes bien sûr et un
matin je découvre qu'un de mes pieds de
tomate était moribond vous savez à ce
moment là dans ma tête
dans ma tête ça a été le refus
catégorique de la maladie j'ai dit non à
la maladie et en m'approchant j'ai eu
l'impression que mon pied de tomate me
demander de l'aide là j'ai plus autorité
cela toute la maladie j'ai dit à la
maladie mais la tomate toi tu va dégager
là parce que ses pieds tomates je ne
l'est pas planté pour qu'ils nient
qu'ils soient malades qu'ils meurent
c'est pour qu'ils portent beaucoup de
tomates et puis je me suis adressé aux
pieds de tomates en lui disant toi pied
thomas qui en excellente santé
tu vas porter beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de tomates et c'est ce qui se passe
mais alors il a fallu que je l'aide
mentalement et verbalement
c'est vrai on n'est pas du tout
programmé
on n'est pas du tout programmé pour
communiquer avec la nature on n'est pas
du tout habitué à parler aux fleurs les
arbres aux plantes et aux animaux et je
dirais même au bébé j'ai vu beaucoup de
mères de famille très responsable qui
s'occupe bien de leur bébé
vraiment rien à dire mais oublie de
parler à leur bébé et je pense que parce
qu'il ne parle pas le même langage que
nous ils parlent pas comme nous on a
tendance à quoi qu'on n'a pas besoin de
communiquer avec lui je vous dis si
seulement six seulement en prenez le
temps de s'arrêter de regarder et
d'écouter
je vous assure vous allez finir par
entendre leur petite voix et voir ce qui
se passe dans leur pensée
ce que je veux mettre en évidence ce
soir c'est vraiment notre rôle vital
dans la réhabilitation de la nature la
nature a besoin de nous et nous avons
besoin d'elle dans la nature
tous les éléments sont interdépendantes
et nous en faisons partie et ce soir je
vous invite donc à travailler avec la
nature a vraiment travaillé en harmonie
avec la nature
comme j'ai dit au début quand on
travaille avec la nature
cette nature devient tellement généreuse
qu'il se passe quelque chose de
miraculeux
on aurait dit que la nature s'ouvre sur
notre passage et fait sa belle tant
qu'elle peut pour nous servir parce
qu'elle a été créée pour ça merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]